نعم مراحل متقدمه وصل اليها الفريق الطبي
السعودي العامل على عمليه فصل التوام
السيامي اليمني عبد الله وسلمان الان تم
كما نشاهد تمت عمليه الفصل قبل دقائق فقط
اعلنت الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه الجراح
الشهير الذي يقود الفريق الطبي السعودي
العامل على عمليه الفصل بانه تم فصل
التوام السيامي اليمني سلمان وعبد الله
الان كما نشاهد وصلنا الى مرحله متقدمه
اذا كنا نستطيع رؤيه الدكتور عبد الله
الربيعه بعد عمليه الفصل بان الان كما ذكر
لنا قبل قليل الدكتور عبد الله بان
المرحله ما بعد فصل التوام السيامي اليمني
سلمان وعبد الله لا تقل اهميه وصعوبه عن
المراحل الاولى ومراحل العمل الفصل كون
التوام السيامي سلمان وعبد الله تعتبر
العمليه
عمليه فصلهم معقده جدا لالتباه معقده نواف
اين هم يتصلون يعني الطفلين المسالك
البوليه
نعم كما ذكرتهم
الاتصال لدى التوام بمنطقه البطن والحوض
والمسالك البوليه بالاضافه الى بعض
الاجزاء الاخرى الحساسه عمليه الفصل تمت
فعلا الفريق الطبي قبل دقائق فقط اعلن
الدكتور عبد الله الربيعه بالنجاح عمليه
الفصل
واكد بان المراحل القادمه لا تقل اهميه عن
مرحله فصل التوام السيامي اليمني عبد الله
وسلمان كونها تعتبر مرحله اخرى مرحله من
الترميم والاجراءات الطبيه الاخرى ضمن
العمليه لكن نحن نلاحظ ارتياح كبير لدى
الفريق الطبي السعودي حقيقه 35
طبيب واخصائي وفني نلاحظ ارتياح لديهم
كبير وهذا ربما عاده يعبر عن
التفاؤل والتوقع بنجاح العمليه بنسبه
كامله لا تزال العمليه مستمره تستغرق ربما
اكثر من ثلاث ساعات الى اربع ساعات نحن
الان في مرحله تعتبر حساسه قبل قليل كنا
نتواجد داخل غرفه العمليات ولكن تم
اخراجنا قبل قليل لان هذه المرحله تعتبر
حساسه ولا يجب ان يتواجد داخل غرفه
العمليات الا الفريق الطبي المخصص لعمليه
فصل التوام السيامي اليمني سلمان وعبد
الله لازلنا ننتظر المراحل القادمه وسنكون
متابعين للمراحل الاخرى كما هو مخطط له
لدى كل خطوه بخطوه معك نواف نتمنى لهم
الشفاء العاجل شكرا لك